pro bowl teams were announced on monday
night there are your nfc pro bowl
quarterbacks oh aaron rodgers russell
wilson and kyler murray the three
choices
notably absent hashtag tommy and bruce
arians made the case last week that
brady should be a pro bowl quarterback
when you look at the passing numbers he
should have been one of the three but
the running numbers gave kyler murray
the edge chris and look i don't it's a
snub who cares i mean the irony is that
tom brady spent his entire career
avoiding the game right when he was
named to it the one year where they're
not playing the game is the year he
doesn't make it so he doesn't have to
come up with some cockamamie excuse or
hey i'm in the super bowl most of the
time it's been hey i'm in the super bowl
i don't have to play right in the pro
bowl but even when he's been available
to play in the pro bowl he's avoided it
i don't know should he have gotten in
over kyler murray i think as we sit here
right now this moment i probably would
say no but the problem is the voting is
done
when did it finish mike what was that
four weeks ago right maybe no they no
they they do the fan voting right up
until the very end the fan voting counts
for a third right players count for a
third and coaches count for a third
right all right so i mean the players
you know at least at least the way i
used to when i was in football i mean
usually around week 10 or 11 is when you
voted right and at that point of the
year
brady and the bucks were a little bit
shaky at that point i guess to a degree
i think as we look at it right now that
yeah i'd probably take tom brady over
kyla murray in like the totality of 15
full games with kyla murray and kind of
the sluggish part of the last five six
weeks from him um
you know but but i understand it and you
know kyla murray of course is the new
fad a new thing in football and you're
right you know you can't just take it
through passing stats the rushing stats
are part of kyla murray's game and
that's very important to where i feel
like that needs to be added to the total
thing and conversation sometimes when we
compare these traditional drop back
quarterbacks to these new age
quarterbacks like kyla murray
yeah i i
i i agree with you what do you think
would you go murray or brady what was
your thought right now right now i'd go
brady yeah murray has tailed off but
you're right they do the voting earlier
in the year
and some players are going to benefit
from that
in recent weeks i think brady's been
better and
as a result uh he's not in now in any
other year it wouldn't matter the
reputation gets him in it's kind of
weird to see him for the first year in
the nfc
not even be a serious part of the
conversation but my guess would be if
they were playing a game
and one of those three quarterbacks was
unavailable for whatever reason brady
would be the next man up not that he
would show up for the game i have a
feeling he's number four on that list
and they they always name all the
alternates because we know it's
inevitable the alternates are going to
show up in in droves uh one guy who
definitely got
snubbed in the afc deforest buckner the
colts defensive lineman what are you
what are you kidding me and again it
just shows you that stats drive the bus
so much for people how many sacks does
someone have not not how are they doing
in the f the play-up category but jim
irsay spoke out on behalf of the force
buckner guy he gave up a first round
pick for and gave a bunch of money to i
have some real practical jokers working
for me tonight they tried to tell me to
force bugger to make the pro bowl i said
nice try and to come back with something
more believable that's actually one of
the best tweets i've ever seen from jim
irsay that i mean it really is he's
right i mean i think that's the big
thing he is right and you're right it's
too much stat driven and i'm i'm pulling
up the roster here because there's a lot
of good defensive lineman as far as in
the afc and guys there i mean i
understand it's not easy but
the the point is like when we got chris
jones cameron hayward coleas campbell as
those defensive tackle players they are
all really good there is no doubt none
of them okay and this is no disrespect
to any of them because i think they're
all awesome none of them has been as
good as deforest buckner this year
deforest buckner
arguably is the nfl defensive mvp if
aaron donald's not in football for my
money him miles garrett you know i'm
probably missing another name or two
there that deserves to be in it but
buckner is what yeah right buckner has
been a force so the one that's egregious
to me a little is
coleas campbell claize campbell again i
think he's a hall of fame football
player i'm not trying to disrespect him
in any ways but he was hurt this year
and he's certainly not as dominant as
deforest buckner has been for that that
team so that was one of the ones that
certainly popped out to me more than
more than any other but but i think it's
it gets back to the timing of the voting
think back to week 10. he got injured
yeah right right around then or
and and prior to that he was dominant
right he was dominant and he did have
three sacks against the jaguars but
against the jaguars are the three words
that are critical to that comment
another former jaguar who was motivated
to play the jaguars just like yannick
way uh getting it done for the baltimore
ravens but yeah deforest buckner should
have been
one of these guys somewhere somehow he
should be on the pro bowl team another
guy that was snubbed in the opinion of
tight end
george kittle
robert tonyan rhymes with fun in the
green bay packers
tight end i i don't think his numbers
have been anywhere close to the
stratosphere of like a george kittle but
he does have 10 touchdowns
and george kittle points out that you
know evan evan ingram is a hype machine
has he ever really produced no i you
know i mean yes it's not been
you know special
like but it's pretty damn good he has
the new york fan base behind him he is a
real are they
well you're right that's questionable
he's got some big he's got some big
drops there's no doubt
you know but that i i understand like
what george kittle's saying there i do i
think that's a legitimate argument like
tj hawkinson
he deserves to be on there he is has a
chance to be george kittle i mean he's
that kind of football player he's in the
lions and we're not going to see him a
lot and he's not getting a lot of
national attention but superstar the
tanyan
versus evan ingram thing
i think you can make a certainly a good
case i mean tonya has 10 touchdowns
uh that's a pretty impressive number for
a tight end right now you know but but
onion tony rhymes with funyuns rhymes
with once i heard that first of all i
got it now no desire to eat onions all
due respect to our friends at frito-lay
i love all of your products except
funyuns but i love robert tanyan with
his 10 touchdowns evan ingram has 54
catches on 95 targets that's not exactly
a high success rate 572 yards and one
touchdown yeah this year yeah tonya
rhymes with funyun has 10 times the
touchdowns of evan ingram he got screwed
there's no doubt about that there's no
any other way to say that uh you know i
think evan ingram yeah first round pick
he's got receiver likability
he's had a few big plays this year right
we're like you see him running down the
sidelines and doing stuff like that that
catches people's eyes on highlights but
uh yeah i feel bad for tonion sorry i
gotta get that right
uh ingram is one of these guys who had a
good enough year as a rookie that
created anticipation that he's going to
break out he's going to break out he's
going to break out he's never broken out
but he did enough as a rookie that
there's just this weird sense and and i
think it's fantasy football driven
you know uh and and it just never paid
off and
but it did he's in the pro bowl the game
they're not playing let's take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports